[MUSIC PLAYING]
Are you happy?
Your disobedience has a cost.
After the end of 206, 207 is our main characters
coming to understand what exactly happened in the Marino
house.
There's a mystery of what happened.
How does this relate to Leanne being in their house?
What does the cult believe is going on here?
We won't let you intimidate us, do you hear me?
Servant has a lot of this kind of inappropriate dark humor.
I love that.
It's a very funny and physical episode with Uncle George.
All right.
Just stay here.
What?
No.
It leans into that belief that we
can do all the action, and all of the craziness,
but in a house.
[GROANING]
She's gone.
Just-- Never mind.
This is also a very big episode for Leanne.
Because I think there's a way that the cult
is supposed to behave, and she has broken from that.
Everyone is kind of shifting their positions
and by the end of 7, Leanne changes her position.
And she breaks from her faith.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[GLASS BREAKING]
00:01:31,470 --> 00:01:34:020
[MUSIC PLAYING]